avril 1981 françois mitterrand est en
campagne présidentielle parmi ses
promesses électorales l'instauration des
35 heures quand je parle de
37,3
je veux parler du travail des hommes
travail des machines ou au contraire
plus répartir le travail crée des
emplois dégager du temps libre pour les
salariés voilà les arguments du candidat
socialiste je demande dans simplement
remettre en marche la machine que l'on
fasse tourner tourner tourner encore car
à l'époque les français travaillent 40
heures par semaine et ce depuis 1936
mais à peine au pouvoir françois
mitterrand et son gouvernement
rétropédale finalement ça ne sera pas 35
heures mais 39 payées 39 et non 40 donc
avec une diminution de salaire colère de
la cgt d'un côté il annonce une
réduction de la durée du travail mais de
l'autre il se donne la possibilité de
récupérer en heures supplémentaires et
dans des conditions lui désavantageuse
qui actuellement est de manière à faire
travailler autant que maintenant et
peut-être plus et du côté du patronat
chez ce directeur d'entreprise la mesure
est accueillie avec prudence passé à 39
heures c'est peut-être plus d'embûches
mais avec des contraintes elle n'est pas
certain que nous puissions occupé
intégralement une deuxième équipe ou
même un certain nombre d'heures de plus
ayant des équipes successives
nécessiterait une production beaucoup
plus importante que nous ne sommes pas
certains de pouvoir mettre sur le marché
mais les clients après des mois de
négociations un accord est trouvé entre
les syndicats le patronat et le
gouvernement fin juillet 1981 les 39
heures seront payés 40 une avancée
sociale d'importance salué par pierre
mauroy alors premier ministre
la négociation relancer à mon initiative
celle du gouvernement
a été difficile
les partenaires sociaux ont su la mener
à bien la mesure devient officiel le 13
janvier 1982 après une ordonnance ont
conseil des ministres c'est il ya 40 ans
depuis la durée légale du temps de
travail a encore baissé elle est passée
à 35 heures hebdomadaires en 2000 avec
les lois
[Musique]